[Applause]
around the world businesses filled
hundreds of billions of requests from us
each year we want our flights changed a
purchase refunded a claim reviewed that
takes the labor of millions of agents
who tend to our every need
but soon automation will take over much
of that and it starts with the
painstaking work of this 23 year old my
name is Laura Morales and I'm a chatbot
designer
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you probably know the Dominican Republic
for its beaches but further west in the
country's capital of Santo Domingo
there's a bustling hub of call centers
for American businesses
Laura works for one of them at a company
called out plex you some of L plexus
inquiries are handled by traditional
call center agents over the phone
others are handled by contact center
agents over live written chat last year
the company introduced a third kind of
agent a bot Laura oversees spots for
three us-based clients and these bots
greet customers looking for assistance
online the bots were self simple queries
on their own and the more complicated
questions get escalated to a human
representative me as an agent I used to
take three conversations or just one
call at the time with bots you don't
have that limitation Alexa well I need
an umbrella tomorrow it might rain
tomorrow there's a 54% chance
bots today are everywhere and so the
people who design their speech are in
high demand the job is kind of like
writing a very dry screenplay with a
choose-your-own-adventure element for
the many ways customers will respond the
hard part comes once the bot goes live
often its pre-scripted conversations
don't work out the way Laura and her
team hoped they would so they're
constantly tinkering the way to start a
day with the bots I need to check how
the bot stayed on the previous day so
they go into analytics and my favorite
one is this it's the unmatched phrases
these are the moments when the box
didn't know what the customer wanted
exactly and I can also see how many
kinds or visitors clicked on the first
button or the second button on the main
menu so if my visitors are not
interacting with my menus that means
that maybe something is not right
so it's interesting because
you used to be coaching the human nation
who's me and now you're coaching a robot
it's that easier or harder it's easier
you don't have to worry about hurting a
BOTS feeling you're not emotional about
it you're just doing what you need to do
for getting the results you want
[Music]
Laura grew up hearing all about the
industry has a banty cuatro años yo
commence a escuchar Lokeren local centre
instead Asiya que ser el negocio del
futuro
este Ingres aan de gente luego fuy
Escalon oposición ease in entiendo que
ahora mismo Aki rebel communica es mucha
gente joven que necesita trabajar y los
call center sunnah wa noxian para a o
Lord started out as an entry-level agent
when she was 17 and worked their way up
last year she was chosen to manage her
company's first interactive chat bot and
today makes about eight dollars an hour
but just four times what she earned when
she first became an agent the transition
to work on chat BOTS took about three
months to learn various aspects of the
job including training on special
software that doesn't require her to
code Laura immediately saw the benefits
a bot is never late a bot doesn't get
sick or pregnant those specific human
situations that you can't fight
automation is able to take that out but
her mom had some hesitations lo ve super
interesante la verdad
tambien pence a body's placer a los
representante Lisa sent it amor
for now the introduction of the bots
hasn't led to any layoffs because
they've helped out Plex win more
business the company has actually hired
more human agents to handle the
enquiries that get escalated from the
bots but as the technology gets better
it's hard not to worry about how this is
all gonna play out and that was a
conversation that required some strong
dominican room eventually surely we will
need fewer human call center agents than
we do now Automation is our reality and
the skill set but you will need to work
at this industry it's going to be
different from the regular agents you
have today I do believe it will get more
technical it will not be dealing with a
customer anymore it will be monitoring
the software and if you don't adapt you
will need to do something else is there
a small part of you that feels guilty
for automating away the job that gave
you your start in your career and is a
job of a lot of your colleagues right
now not at all
like zero guilt here we go yeah yeah
zero hesitation
it's got its happening already you might
as well be a part of it thank God I'm
part of it
whether you're a grocer doctor factory
worker journalist all of our jobs will
soon be reshaped by automation some will
benefit from the new work that will
emerge and others will watch their jobs
disappear with no clear path to another
livelihood managing this transition will
be the defining challenge for us in the
decades ahead and we need to be ready
for it
[Music]